[Music]
these snails
i have take i have engineered them you
think snails
are slow i've made them fast oh god
this snail i have infused with my dna
to go faster than in his name ha
snail go fast funny this snail go fast
on water
[Music]
my three snails hillary claire
my three snails hillary trump
squatter will race for my love
can we take them away
[Music]
the snails will raise science
i have the gay saleman who i entrust
with hillary gay saleman
get hillary
she's a quick one handle have a respect
and dignity follow me my child
make sure hillary goes at least 20 miles
per hour
go
make it go the [ __ ] are you doing
pushing
push it
well done hillary well done you're doing
great
you're doing you're totally going to win
the election i've trained this snail
my whole life that snail knows what it's
doing
oh hilary she's a crazy [ __ ]
oh oh hillary
that crazy [ __ ] the next sailor
is trump he goes hard he's very rich
he's got a nice butt
and he will be controlled by tip
[Music]
tim can i trust you with trump
slap it i always
wow what the [ __ ] are you doing
mr pimp you've got trump sent him in
very good he's going to wreck that [ __ ]
oh
oh oh [ __ ] go trump
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] sinking what the
[ __ ] are you doing
give me the push i got your legs i got
your legs get them
get them off come on come on trump
come up yeah yeah
give me that give me chad you piece of
[Music]
[ __ ]
i will send out my achievement
squad i've infused him mid mine on
dna some say he's faster than keemstar
fast as [ __ ]
my son it's time
go go
yes [ __ ]
did we pick the worst [ __ ] lake ever
like what
fire the cannon
send in the helicopter
tiniest ghost of wind dude
yes
[Music]
what are you laughing at it's not good
you think this is funny
[Music]
what
sweat
michael will you go in for me
we fled to argentina
me and squirtle made it back safe
but what we didn't know was that the
greatest
boat was hillary
[Music]
and what we didn't know was that hillary
would sail across the atlantic
she would sail to america to become
[Music]
president